four votes KC four votes Tyler it comes
down to Bailey's vote which is the last
one congratulations
[Applause]
let's go $500,000 hitting your bank
account soon has it sunk in yet has it
not at all not even a little bit I mean
I I'm super excited but it hasn't
something yet it barely funkin that I
was on Big Brother so it's crazy yeah
you just spent almost a hundred days
right in there you're free now I know
I'm so excited to be free I could not
wait especially the last couple weeks do
you know a week it was like I can't wait
to get out I can't wait to get out I
can't wait to get out I'm so ready I'm
so ready and so now I'm here and the day
has come
finale and it's perfect dude it's
perfect
what's the first thing you're gonna do
when they let you out those doors guys
talk to my friends and family I talk to
my friends family hang out
I don't know catch up on life catch up
on the world I feel like I've definitely
missed so much so I'm so excited
your mom was sitting front row bawling
her eyes out as it came down to it what
did it mean to see her right there it
meant everything cuz I didn't think she
was gonna be at the finale I thought she
was still in the Philippines and just
see her there and my dad it was
everything there in my number-one fans
I'm on the field they're just always you
know on the stands just yelling and
going crazy and so it was awesome and
for me to walk out as winning the whole
thing and seeing them see me everything
five to four is what it came down to was
that a shocker to you or did you think
it's gonna be close um I I didn't think
it was gonna be that close I really
didn't um it was definitely a nail-biter
I kept saying his name Tyler Tyler I'm
like a v1 cool um but I ended up taking
it so everything happens for a reason
yes Julie's pulling those keys out did
you think oh he won this like yeah Tyler
Tyler and then I kind of just lost track
there and I was like he's taking it but
yeah you said you're gonna take that
five hundred thousand dollars spend it
on your family what does that mean what
are you gonna do with them um just
whatever to make life easier for them in
any way that I can you know whether it's
just living situation you know in the
Philippines out here and there's a lot
of work to be done so whatever I can do
to help my family and make things easier
for them and set us up for the future
and help whoever you know
it's all positive things for sure that's
beautiful now you really won in this
game when it counted to win you want
five Ito's which is a tie for the most
vetoes ever won in a season yes it's a
year in the Hall of Fame a big brother
wasn't your strategy to lay low until it
was Jerry time and then play hard or was
that just how it wound up yes so in the
very beginning before coming into the
house is like okay I strategy I know my
social game was gonna take me very very
far in the beginning I want to stay as
low as possible
not too many blood on my hands less is
more I don't talk about game you know
and people always said that from the
other side of the house Casey never
talks about game and so I didn't want to
say too much less is more and then I
didn't play my first veto to day 46 I
didn't play anything in the beginning I
was frustrated so I was one of the last
people I got to play veto and once I
started playing then I started you know
like you know I played a clean game you
kept your word to people you didn't turn
on anybody
there was another side of the house
there was level six on the other side
has anybody revealed to you the name of
that side of the house Tyler said a
couple names like I don't know okay or I
burst it was foul a which stood for five
of us till the end yeah which didn't
didn't work out and then they changed it
to the hive no level six a right six man
so legit so solid and I love us now you
had to make some tough decisions in the
end there first you say goodbye to
Angela no do you regret that at all no I
had to do that you know I had the final
two with Tyler and I had two of my best
friends on the block and I made the
final two with Tyler so I had to take
him you know as much as it sucks so bad
because I care about him so much
I had to do what I had to do I had to
stick to my words now some people
watching tonight probably went when you
said I'm gonna take Tyler when it's such
an easy win against JC yeah but you
stuck to your word of playing a clean
game and sticking to what the promises
you made at any point did you regret or
have a moment of thought of like oh I
shouldn't have brought him I wasn't even
thinking that as the votes were going
Tyler Tyler it never even split my mind
like okay maybe I should
JC it didn't slip on my it really didn't
so which is the weirdest thing to wrap
things up here you did say when you
evicted Angela you're like the people
out there don't know the person I met in
here yeah cuz it was she had she had a
tough time with yours this season Mira's
called her furniture for the first half
of the season because she just kind of
sat back I didn't know that yeah I mean
I was moreso talking about the people
like the past houseguests that were
throwing her just personal attacks you
know and I was really close with Angela
since the very beginning so I knew who
she was as a person and why she was like
that furnishers I guess who I whatever
that that's pretty interesting but um so
I I kind of had a better idea than other
house guests
so for her them to personally attack her
it hurt my feelings because that's not
how she is you know so it's definitely
not how she is well you're gonna go down
as one of the best Big Brother players
of all time I know you just got out of
there why would you go back in and play
an all-star season right now I don't
know I'm just go say I don't know but
yeah I don't know how be in the year two
so let the check clear let another year
go by and then we'll talk just crazy
it's crazy
[Music]